Hablemos sobre sucesiones geométricas
-sucesiones geométricas-, que son una
clase de sucesiones donde empezamos con un
cierto número y cada término siguiente es
el término anterior multiplicado por el mismo
valor. Entonces, ¿de qué estoy hablando? Bueno,
lo que haremos para obtener el segundo término
es multiplicar a por r, así obtenemos ar;
para obtener el tercer término multiplicaremos el
segundo de nuevo por r, entonces, ¿qué obtenemos?,
bueno, obtenemos ar². Si multiplicamos por r de
nuevo, obtenemos el cuarto término que es ar³,
y podemos seguir y seguir. Esta es la forma en la
que definimos una sucesión geométrica infinita;
podemos seguir y seguir y seguir y seguir.
Ahora, existen varias formas de denotar la
misma sucesión. Podemos definirla también de
manera explícita. Podemos decir que esta es la
sucesión a subíndice n que empieza en n = 1 en el
primer término y va hasta infinito con a subíndice
n igual a... Y, bueno, podemos verlo por aquí,
cualquier término de esta sucesión será ar elevado
a la... y tengamos cuidado por aquí, a es lo mismo
que ar elevado a la potencia 0, ya que r elevado a
la 0 es 1; el segundo término es ar¹, el tercer
término es ar², así que parece que el enésimo
término será ar elevado a la potencia n - 1. Y
podemos comprobarlo: si queremos, por ejemplo,
el segundo término, tenemos ar²¯¹, que es ar¹ que
es ar, funciona. Así que de esta forma podemos
definir la sucesión de manera explícita. También
podemos definirla de manera recursiva: la sucesión
a subíndice n, desde n = 1 hasta ∞, con a₁ = a,
este es el caso base, ar elevado a la 0 es sólo a,
y luego podemos decir que el término a subíndice
n es igual al término anterior a subíndice n - 1
por r, para n ≥ 2. Así que esto está diciendo:
"Mira, nuestro primer término será a -este de
aquí es a- ar⁰ es sólo a, y después cada término
siguiente será igual al término anterior por r",
que es exactamente lo que hicimos por aquí.
Así que veamos algunas sucesiones geométricas.
Por ejemplo, podemos tener la siguiente
sucesión: a subíndice n, desde n = 1 hasta ∞,
con a subíndice n igual a no sé, digamos que
el primer término es, es 20, y r, es decir, el
número por el cual multiplicamos para obtener el
siguiente término, supongamos que es 1/2, 20 (1/2)
elevado a la n - 1. ¿Cómo se ve esta sucesión?
Bueno, el primer término es 20, si n = 1, tenemos
20 (1/2) elevado a la potencia 1 - 1, es
decir, 1/2 elevado a la potencia 0, lo cual es 1,
1 x 20 es 20, y entonces el primer término es 20.
Y para obtener cada término siguiente, ¿por cuánto
tenemos que multiplicar? Bueno, en este ejemplo
estamos multiplicando por 1/2, 20 (1/2) es 10,
10 (1/2) es 5, 5 (1/2) es 2.5 pero lo escribiremos
como fracción 5/2, y 5/2 x 1/2 es 5/4, y podemos
seguir y seguir y seguir. Esta es una sucesión
geométrica. Ahora te voy a dar una sucesión nueva,
y quiero que me digas si es geométrica o no.
Digamos que empezamos en 1, después tenemos 2,
después 6, y después tenemos 24, y después tenemos
120 y podemos seguir y seguir. ¿Es geométrica esta
sucesión? Bueno, pensemos qué es lo que pasa:
para pasar de 1 a 2 multiplicamos por 2, para
pasar de 2 a 6 multiplicamos por 3, para pasar de
6 a 24 multiplicamos por 4; así que, observa:
no estamos multiplicando siempre por la misma
cantidad, mientras que, recuerda, en una sucesión
geométrica siempre debemos multiplicar por la
misma cantidad. Aquí estamos multiplicando por
cantidades distintas, es decir, esta sucesión que
acabamos de construir tiene esta forma: tenemos el
primer término; el segundo término es dos veces el
primer término, 2 • a; el tercer término es tres
veces el segundo término, es decir, 3 • 2 • a; el
cuarto término es cuatro veces el tercer término:
4 • 3 • 2 • a, y podemos seguir y seguir. Y esta
sucesión, que no es una sucesión geométrica,
también podemos definirla explícitamente como la
sucesión a subíndice n desde n = 1 hasta ∞, con a
subíndice n igual a... Y veamos: el cuarto término
es 4 factorial por a, de hecho si vemos este caso
de arriba en particular, donde a es 1, tenemos
que el primer término es 1, el segundo es 2 • 1,
el tercero es 3 • 2 • 1, el cuarto es 4 • 3 • 2
• 1, y por lo tanto a subíndice n = n factorial.
Esta sucesión que tenemos aquí, la cual no es
una sucesión geométrica, describe exactamente
esta sucesión de aquí, esta es la forma explícita
de esta sucesión y también podríamos definirla de
manera recursiva. Podemos decir: a subíndice
n desde n = 1 hasta ∞, con a subíndice 1 = 1;
este es nuestro primer término, y cada término
siguiente será igual al término anterior por n,
es decir, el segundo término es el
término anterior por 2, por lo tanto,
el término n será igual al término n - 1 • n. Y
esta es otra forma válida de definir una sucesión.